we're learning more and more about the
timeline and sequence of events
surrounding what we now know to be
undeniable confirmed intent to collude
with Russia for the benefit of Donald
Trump's candidacy and the claim that
we've heard now from both Donald Trump
jr. and Donald from senior and a bunch
of other people that Donald Trump the
president didn't know anything about
Donald Trump juniors meeting with this
Russian lawyer presumably to get dirt
about Hillary Clinton until just a few
days ago
that out that assertion is increasingly
suspect the New York Times and a number
of other media outlets have put together
the timeline of it started with well on
the day of the meeting was Donald Trump
at Trump Tower and we determined that
yes indeed he was but there's actually a
series of public events and bullet
points time points that we can look at
which make the assertion that Trump was
just completely clueless about this very
very difficult to believe let's put the
timeline up on the screen for people who
are watching with us let's go back to
June 7th at 6:14 p.m. June 7th at 6:14
p.m. Donald Trump jr. confirmed the
meeting with the Russian lawyer a
meeting ostensibly believed to be the
intent of the meeting being that the
Russian lawyer had dirt on Hillary
Clinton for the Trump campaign that was
confirmed by Donald Trump jr. at 6:14
p.m. Eastern Time on June 7th now in
that confirmation Donald Trump jr.
explained that he would love it if there
was dirt on Hillary Clinton he said that
he would get the Russian lawyers name to
security and upon being told that this
meeting was part of the broader Russian
campaign to help his dad become
President of the United States he seems
completely unfazed by it in a way that
suggests that was not the first time
that he was hearing that just three
hours later on that same day June 7th of
2016 Donald Trump promises promised to
give a speech exposing what he described
as Hillary Clinton's corrupt dealings
and favorable treatment to foreign
governments including Russia which
would have been exactly the type of
information that they would have been
expecting to receive at the three hour
old
scheduling of this meeting with a
Russian lawyer that in and of itself is
very odd timing skip to June ninth two
days later 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time when
the actual meeting took place Donald
Trump jr. Jared Kushner and Paul
Manafort met with the Russian lawyer
this is the meeting that was confirmed
on June 7th it actually took place on
June 9th at 4:00 p.m. we now know that
Donald Trump senior was at Trump Tower
at that point the time of the meeting
just 40 minutes later and remember we
were told this was a short meeting in
fact Donald Trump jr. said to Sean
Hannity in an interview two nights ago
the meeting was 20 or 30 minutes long
40 minutes after Pat the meeting
presumably started at 4:40 p.m. Eastern
on June 9th Donald Trump goes to Twitter
and all of a sudden is tweeting about
Hillary Clinton's deleted emails and we
actually have the tweet to show you
Donald Trump 4:40 p.m. on the dot June 9
2016 how long did it take your staff of
823 people to think that up and where
are your 33,000 emails that you deleted
the White House was asked about this
obviously suspicious timing they said it
is merely a coincidence do you believe
in this type of coincidence at this
point Pat that would take something
otherworldly I would say and then within
the next month you had the DNC hacked
email starting to get released yes you
had Trump during a speech publicly
inviting the Russians to find the 30,000
missing emails from Hillary Clinton I
mean it just doesn't make any sense and
I think these people maybe they're
criminals but they're certainly not
smart criminals they're not criminal
geniuses let's know it that way I think
what happened is the following the
meeting is scheduled to talk about this
in more detail Donald Trump clearly
hears about the meeting he gets very
very excited and he starts teasing at
this speech off-the-cuff we're going to
get some really good stuff on Hillary
Clinton really really soon the meeting
then happens it's about what Russia
collected they're clearly willing to
eret with the Trump campaign we heard
from Donald Trump jr. that Jared Kushner
didn't stay in the meeting long maybe
the reason he left the meeting so
quickly as he was so excited himself
about this that he went to tell Donald
Trump senior about it I don't know were
sort of speculating and then Donald
Trump even more excited at this point
starts tweeting about it to Hillary
Clinton with the hope that she'll get
scared or whatever the case may be
that's a pretty reasonable scenario for
what went on here given everything we
know about the personalities and
histories of these individuals exactly I
think most people would have the
foresight and the self-control to just
let this whole thing simmer for a little
bit sure but that's just not in their
nature Donald Trump goes directly to
Twitter and do we really believe
anything that Trump says at this point
the trend is they are willing to admit
only what has broken in the news or is
about to break in the news the Trump jr.
emails are a great example of this
Donald Trump jr. a couple days ago
deciding to release the full email chain
in the interests of transparency the
truth is that the New York Times had
that email chain and was about to
release it and Donald Trump attempted to
Don from jr. attempted to mitigate some
of the potential damage it would do by
releasing it himself
supposedly because of transparency they
will only admit to what has already been
reported and is undeniable or is about
to be reported by media and usually when
these things break Trump senior will go
to Twitter and try to debunk it the best
that he can whether state a nun who's a
whatever isn't for this instance he
really couldn't all he said was that his
son was being open and transparent so I
guess it's okay think about how much is
publicly known about this right now and
just imagine what Robert Moeller the
special prosecutor in the Russia Trump
investigation might have right now